[Music]
our brothers and sisters are in
desperate need of assistance to serve
the people you are the help that's
coming
the novel nation is the largest tribe in
the United States 27 000 square miles
that we have the patrol an increase in
criminal activity has come upon us
to offer the Basic Police Services we
would need 500 officers we have 180.
quite frankly our lives are at stake
seven
but any other
on the Navajo Nation everyone knows each
other I am worried about my dad's side
finding out they hate cops I'm scared
for her but I know she can handle
herself they're leaving left and right
and that's kind of got me worried if you
think you can handle it don't quit I
think it's dire some people aren't
prepared mentally emotionally to deal
with it in the long run you're okay
control
I'm willing to put my life at risk I'm
pretty scared though I've tried to tell
myself keep pushing forward
stay where you are
it's been a rough couple years we're
ready to move forward the success of the
Navajo Police Academy could break or
make the nation